hmm
what no i know
she does look shocked to meet the real
us doesn't she
what's up folks carlos here in the
penultimate episode of one division
we're given a tour of wanda's history
much of which has been a mystery to even
herself her tour guide slash unwitting
therapist and all this
the artist formerly known as agnes
agatha harkness
yeah big time spoilers ahead people this
is et canada's nerdless
now before we get into wanda's story we
get a glimpse at agatha's as we're taken
back to the salem witch trials
where we see the origin of her dark
[Music]
magic
[Music]
in the present day agatha is monologuing
like a true super villain
revealing her intentions she's convinced
wanda is a witch
and needs to figure out how she's doing
the whole west view thing
in order to do that she opens a door to
wanda's past
forcing her to confront the traumatic
experiences that have brought her to use
her powers like she has
creating this reality it's like the
ghost of christmas past in a christmas
carol
except way darker this is your pick yes
season 2 episode 21
dick van dyke again always sitcom sitcom
sitcom
wanda's connection to classic american
sitcoms is outlined right away
her dad sells copies of them out on the
war-torn streets of sokovia
and as battles rage outside sitcoms are
a way for the maximoff family to find
some comfort and happiness
it's here that wanda has to relive her
first major trauma
the explosion that killed her parents
and the stark industry's bomb that would
eventually entwine her life
with the avengers in order to save
herself and pietro she uses her powers
for the first time
behind door number two is wanda's time
at hydra
due to the abilities she still doesn't
know she has she survives her
experiments with loki scepter and has
her first meeting
with the mind stone that vision she sees
in the middle of it all
that that is some serious foreshadowing
we'll
come back to that later also don't sleep
on that brady bunch episode she's
watching
informs both her desire for her family
and the affection she'll eventually have
for the vision
[Music]
if any of what just happened wasn't
clear to the viewer agatha
pretty much spells it out claiming the
mind stone enhanced juan's latent powers
now flash forward to the avengers
compound as wanda and vision are
watching a classic episode of malcolm in
the middle
she opens up to him about her trauma and
feeling of loss and he offers to be
there for her
and we see the beginning of their bond
i've never experienced loss because
i've never had a loved one to lose
but what is grief if not
love persevering that's a
smart sympathoid right there now after
adding up these traumatic moments agatha
needs to see
one more how did wanda get vision back
now if you'll remember earlier in the
series sword director hayward claimed
that wanda broke into the sword facility
and stole
vision's body here we see that the truth
is quite different
confirming something that we all know
hayward
sucks he deserves a funeral at least
i deserve it yeah wanda's purpose of
visiting sword is to retrieve vision's
body and give him a proper burial
hero there's something else in mind
however and shows her that they're
dismantling him
saying vision is a weapon and sword
doesn't want him brought back to life
i can't feel you after seeing vision one
last time and
maybe inadvertently putting a little hex
power into his lifeless form
wanda leaves and drives through west
view
now we see the residents how they really
are herb mrs hart
a guy with a mustache story i can't
remember his name she arrives at the
plot of land that she envisioned we're
going to build a house on
to grow old in overcome by her grief and
anger she lets loose with power and
creates her ideal 50th sitcom reality
what comes next is a genuine surprise
with the mind stone power that's inside
her she constructs a whole
new vision of course you'll remember
that
vision himself was brought to life using
the mind stone
juana never stole his body or or brought
that vision back to life
believing he was truly dead she made
this version of him
this explains why he has no memory of
life before westview why he couldn't
leave
and why hayward just stood there
watching when he tried
hayward you sneaky bastard back in
reality agatha has wanted his kids
trapped seeing her as a threat
after having figured out wanda's true
power chaos magic she calls her by a
name that we all know but has never been
heard in the mcu before
scarlet [ __ ] that's right jimmy
she got her name now clearly we'll be
getting a showdown between these two
next episode
and maybe it lead into wanda becoming
the figure she saw
back in her hydra days so at this point
you might be saying to yourself carlos
this is this is a lot well hold on to
your infinity gems folks
because we get a doozy of a mid credit
[Music]
scene
you see sword wasn't just disassembling
vision they were rebuilding him to use
as their own weapon
and all they needed was a little wanda
magic to bring him back to life
this is a great easter egg for comics
fans as a similar disassembling happened
to vision decades ago in the books
when vision was put together again he
lost his colors
and his humanity now given this big
mid-credits reveal
i'm wondering is that actor paul bettany
has been talking about the one that he
has fireworks with
just himself like is he excited
to have vision versus vision on your
screen what i'm curious about is how
this episode's revelations potentially
play into the idea of wanda and pietro
actually being mutants her powers
manifested at a young age
like mutant powers typically do is what
agatha interpreting as magic
actually the first instance of someone
using their mutant powers in the mcu
speaking of mutants i for one i'm still
holding out hope for an appearance
from magneto maybe it'll be uh ian
mckellen literally last minute like luke
at the end of mando
taking wanda away exactly like luke did
with grogu
probably wrong but a guy can dream
alright folks one episode left who do
you think is the true villain of
wandavision
and what twists and surprises are left
for us sound off in the comments below
if you like this video
please give us the old thumbs up and
check out our other in-depth interviews
and stories
i'm carlos bustamante you can find me on
instagram at low spot
have a good one folks i'll see you next
[Music]
time
you